der ukrainische Präsidentin Cockpit
einer F16 selensky weiß um die
Symbolkraft der Bilder dänemark will die
ersten sechs Kampfjets schon zum
Jahreswechsel übergeben 19
Kampfflugzeuge sind versprochen weitere
F16 hat die Niederlande zugesagt
ich danke Ihnen und ganz Dänemark für
all die Waffen die sie zum Schutz der
Freiheit zur Verfügung stellen
und für die F16 die wir vereinbart haben
die Zusagen aus Kopenhagen und Den Haag
erhöhen den Druck auf Berlin ob und wann
die Bundesregierung für die von Kiew
gewünschten Taurus Marschflugkörper
entscheide wurde der Regierungssprecher
gestern gefragt der ließ die Frage
weiter offen etwas auskunftsfreudiger
die grüne aus Ministerin bärburg sprach
sich am Rande einer Pressekonferenz
indirekt für eine rasche Taurus
Entscheidung aus
das ist auf jeden Fall darauf ankommt
dass er mir glaube ich in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren nicht nur eindrücklich
sondern auf brutale Art und Weise
erleben müssen
beide Kriegsparteien haben in den
vergangenen Tagen von eigenen Vorstößen
berichtet bei der russisch
kontrollierten Stadt Bach Mut erzielte
die ukrainische Armee nach eigenen
Angaben Gelände Gewinne in einer
Größenordnung von 43 Quadratkilometern
russland sieht in der angekündigten
Lieferung von F16 Kampfjets an die
Ukraine eine weitere militärische
Eskalation in Kiew dagegen glaubt man
durch die Kampfflugzeuge den
Kriegsverlauf zu seinen Gunsten
verändern zu können die
Luftüberlegenheit heißt es sei der
Schlüssel zum Erfolg am Boden
inwieweit die F16 tatsächlich zum
gamechanger werden könnten ist unter
Experten allerdings umstritten
also machen die Kampfflugzeuge den
entscheidenden Unterschied fragen wir
Christian Mölling verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitsexperte von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
schönen guten Morgen hallo guten Morgen
die Chats aus Dänemark und in den
Niederlanden werden wir erst zum
Jahreswechsel geliefert eigentlich doch
zu spät für die jetzt laufende
ukrainische gegen offensive oder absolut
aber es ist auch ein wichtiger Finger
zeigt dass man diesen Krieg eben nicht
nur in Tagen Wochen denken kann wie wir
das so in tagespolitischen Geschäft
machen sondern das tatsächlich eher um
halbjahresscheiben und jahresschreiben
geht es war von Anfang an klar ist der
Ausbildung der Piloten lange dauern wird
auch das Bodenpersonals das aber auch
die Sicherung der Ukraine in der Aufgabe
ist die für die nächste Dekade steht in
Deutschland wird ja darüber diskutiert
Taurus Marschflugkörper zu liefern
steigt der nun mit den F16 Jets aus
Dänemark und die Niederlande der Druck
auf die Bundesregierung da eine
Entscheidung zu treffen und was können
die überhaupt bewirken nee die Lieferung
der Taurus Flugkörper wäre schon
sinnvoll weil sie einfach die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Ukraine noch mal
deutlich wieder verlängern würde gar
nicht erweitern würde denn Frankreich
und Großbritannien haben ja
waffenähnlicher Art schon geliefert das
heißt also auch diese Frage der
Eskalation ist eigentlich kein Thema
hier kommt keine neue Qualität bloß es
bedeutet dass die Ukraine
durchhaltefähiger ist mit Blick auf lang
reichweitige Waffen und damit die
Möglichkeit auch diesen Krieg quasi
nicht vorne im auf dem Schlachtfeld zu
entscheiden sondern in der Logistik in
dem man hinten versucht sozusagen alles
was mit Munition und tanken zu tun hat
auszuschalten man hat ja das Gefühl der
Konflikt ist irgendwie festgefahren die
Unterstützung aus dem Westen kommt
stückweise und russlands Präsident Putin
scheint auf Zeit zu spielen oder ja
natürlich eine andere Option bleibt ihm
auch nicht also ein schlechter Krieg ist
immer noch besser als ein schlechter
Frieden denn das würde bedeuten im
Augenblick eines Friedens das alle die
in diesem Krieg auf russischer Seite
investiert haben sagen würden okay es
ist Zahltag was haben wir denn
rausgekriegt und das würde glaube ich
eine schlechte Bilanz für Putin bedeuten
die Ukraine hängt deswegen ist es auch
nicht so hilfreich immer auf einzelne
Waffen Zukunft gucken hängt vom
permanenten Strom von Waffen Munition
etc aus dem Westen ab weil es noch nicht
in der Lage ist sich selber zu versorgen
das wird auch lange dauern deswegen
müssen wir auch da gucken dass wir die
Ukraine langfristig nicht nur
militärischen auch rüstungsindustriell
in Europa und die transatlantischen Raum
integrieren nach Einschätzung britischer
Geheimdienste reagiert Russland mit der
Bildung einer neuen Armee im Süden wie
ist das einzuschätzen
das Russland weiterhin versucht
natürlich eine Gegenwehr zu bringen ist
völlig klar für Russland ist zurzeit
eines der großen Probleme Personal zu
haben das heißt aber nicht das ist nicht
irgendwann neues Personal gibt wir haben
jetzt gerade in Zeitfenster wo ist ein
Problem mit den Reserven hat das wird es
irgendwann aber wieder in den Griff
bekommen deswegen gibt es auch da so
eine Art von Wellenbewegung ist aber
viel über den Krieg vor Ort gesprochen
über Aufrüstung über Waffenlieferungen
sehen Sie denn überhaupt zur Zeit
Möglichkeiten für Verhandlungen es gibt
ja Initiativen zuletzt die Ukraine
Gespräche mit über 40 Nationen im
saudi-arabischen Gitter
wie viel bringt das ich glaube dass man
überall wo es geht vortasten kann
allerdings Verhandlungen im Sinne von
Russland spricht mit der Ukraine bis zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht ausgeschlossen
sondern schließen die Partner und ihre
militärischen Ziele und politischen
Ziele zur Zeit erstmal noch aus das
bedeutet nicht dass man sich nicht
Gedanken darüber machen kann wie es
aussieht denn wir müssen ja jetzt auch
schon den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
planen ich glaube man muss aber sich im
Klaren darüber sein dass weil eben
politische Ziele mit militärischen
Mitteln verfolgt werden der Einsatz ist
Militär etwas ist was mit den
Verhandlungen direkt zu tun hat nämlich
die Frage kann ich noch erreichen was
ich will mit militärischen Mitteln oder
gehe ich jetzt in die Verhandlungen weil
es sinnvoll ist dann das was ich
erreicht habe zu sichern trotzdem muss
es ja Gedankenspiele geben wie ein Ende
des Krieges der Kampfhandlungen aussehen
könnte und es gab da Schlagzeilen aus
Brüssel aus dem NATO Hauptquartier der
Staatschef von NATO Generalsekretär
stolkenberg hatte kürzlich einen Deal
mit Russland ins Spiel gebracht die
Ukraine tritt Gebiete ab an Russland
dafür wird die Ukraine nahezu Mitglied
dieser Staatschef hatte dann nach
heftiger Kritik aus der Ukraine sich für
seinen Vorschlag entschuldigt aber sind
das Gedankenspiele über die gesprochen
wird auf natoebene vielleicht auch mit
der Ukraine und wie realistisch ist das
ja also dieses Gedankenspiel ist nicht
das Gedankenspiel des NATO Mitarbeiters
gewesen sondern etwas was ihm
präsentiert worden ist worauf reagiert
und das war sicherlich ein PR Fehler den
er da gemacht hat
Gedankenspiele kann jeder machen das ist
die haben gesagt Anfang des Krieges die
Frage tauscht man Land gegen Frieden wir
wissen dass das seit 2014 nicht
funktioniert hat denn die Frage ist das
hat ja am Ende etwas zu tun mit einer
ganz essentiellen Sachen nämlich
Vertrauen glauben Sie dass der Gegenüber
also Putin die Zusage die er gemacht hat
einhält und wie wollen Sie das absichern
wenn sie sich dem nicht sicher sein
können und da kommen sie wieder zurück
zum militärischen Lösung denn das ist
das was äh das Mittel der Wahl ist das
Russland gewählt hat es hat zum
Äußersten gegriffen und die Frage ist
wie soll man Vertrauen wieder herstellen
zu ange Ukraine war dass der
Sicherheitsexperte Christian Mölling von
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
vielen Dank für das ist